[Music]
hello hello and welcome to playstation
grenade
it's that time of year once again fort
nightmares has arrived and things
are getting a little spoopy if you're
new around these parts this is the
series in which we look at the secrets
and easter eggs hidden away
in the map of fortnite battle royale and
then we attempt to piece together the
storyline
so slap code adamaru in the store to
support this nonsense
and let's break down chapter two season
four week nine
let's go
[Music]
this week i decided to try and find a
halloween easter egg i never saw for
myself last year
i rushed down to camp card and the
gravestones here to hopefully
spot a ghost escaping did you see the
footage last year
but to my surprise look at what hath
returned to this area
the chapter one barn is back about a
month ago this spot
vanished completely gone without a trace
and took with it
all our chapter one memories little did
we know they would return at halloween
including the sacred broken clock from
the og
tilted towers remember the first island
it was great wasn't it anyway
the reason i came down here to this spot
was to find the ghost easter egg
i didn't find it but little did i know i
will find it somewhere else
up at the top of the island there are
houses here slowly being thrown into the
sea
thanks to the coastline eroding this
spot has one of the original dummy
chests
who is literally my only friend in
fortnite this part of the map
always gets the halloween vibes and goes
full throttle into the witchcraft
and just like last year this house here
is a tourist attraction again
and this means the return of the
gargoyles stone goblins of horror are
watching you everywhere
they're even watching the tv too and
every so often their eyes glow purple to
show signs of life
this is seriously spooky stuff but that
is not the end of this tale
make your way upstairs for a gruesome
sight two gargoyles have entranced
graham the gnome let's hope this story
doesn't continue and graham can go back
to plotting the downfall of the
nominator
more on him soon so as i was saying
about the ghost easter egg we try
and find it every year well this year is
no longer just at the gravestones in
camp cod
because i found it here at the ghost
house
check it out i do like missable easter
eggs but i hope this isn't found
everywhere on the map
in this house are many decorations
featuring far too many ghosts for
comfort
we may need to call the ghostbusters if
you didn't visit this part of the map
last year i truly recommend it
come see some random spiders riding each
other
i could have put that better and gnomes
and bears stuck in spiderwebs
last week we witnessed the return of
midas chair at the authority
we all guessed how he would make it back
into the game and most of you were right
midas is now a boss who can be found at
the authority
at this point i need your myths please
what tests would you like us to conduct
on the gold man of halloween
or any myths you have about the
halloween update before it leaves in
about two weeks
please hit me in the comments and i'll
get the myths chased i digress
here at the authority the golden chair
is currently floating
as if it's cursed and has been possessed
the candles on the ground
indicate this is witchcraft but who
could be responsible
maybe the henchman who served under
midas maybe it's jules
because that relationship was never
really explained if it was the henchman
this would also make sense of the ghost
henchmen at the authority right now
and once we are eliminated in game we
become shadows
midas shadows hmm midas returns with
ghost henchmen and we serve him as
shadow henchmen
i feel a fortnight theory coming on do
you think this is part of the main
storyline
or a throwaway fortnight of fortnite
content either way midas is back
and i'm guessing he's here for revenge
on that shark that took him out
never forget i'm still hoping that ghost
brutus could return
next update as his shrine is now missing
but it would be
mere feet and inches away from the
witch's enchantment circle we shall see
by the way i'm sure you've noticed midas
has a purple glow
indicating he's corrupted well that got
me thinking about another new set of
buildings found around the map right now
these witch's cabins look around them
and you'll see the corrupted trees have
returned
we haven't seen these pop up randomly
since chapter one and if i remember
rightly there was a building which
slowly became more and more corrupted
each week
but we never saw the end of that story
because we were all sucked into a black
hole
you should visit these spots for the
detail if you play save the world you've
seen these before but this time there's
added decorations and sweets and candies
everywhere
but i'm going back to my corrupted
thoughts for a moment and i wondered if
all bosses in the game would be now
glowing purple for halloween
so i checked up on iron man i regret
that decision
he's hostile but not part of the undead
now let's go over to something
completely new
baby okay be honest completely with me
right now
i'll give you five seconds can you spot
the update here
good luck
did you find it no well let me show you
the upper level now has a layer of
plaster added
this is mind-blowing stuff you're shook
us to the car right
the update is tiny but it's still an
update towards hot watch's world
domination
last week someone commented that the
henchmen will one day make it over to
hot watch
that would be so good so epic developer
watching right now
come on make these dreams a reality
[Music]
oh segway let's go over to the henchmen
for nine weeks now we've watched them
evolve their bromance from dance offs to
pool parties
to being beated from a dam okay that was
my fault
they've been through a great deal
together at first i couldn't find the
bros so i quickly need to thank those
people who let me know on twitter
bill and ted are now living it up in
sweaty sands
it may be approaching the winter period
but these guys are getting some beach
time in
here's their actions this update okay
the first thing we should know
officially
is that they have alt heads this week
pumpkins for heads
here's a fortnite quiz question for you
can you name the skins that those
masks come from flex in the comments
i'll try and heart your comment
we start by finding them practicing
martial arts on the beach
they know the future may bring conflict
and they need to scrub up
on their melee skills then to unwind
they go fishing
although it seems like it's mind fishing
weird next more beach shenanigans and
then the bros
go for some food first they grab a taco
fist or two at the local taco stand
and uh celebrate their actions next the
two go back onto the deck of the pier
and grab a pizza
before my favorite moment buy the movie
equipment
a loving wave to the camera and finally
they finished their meals and hit the
ice cream parlor to wolf down heaps of
candy
or i wonder where they'll be next time
here's a totally inaccurate guess
maybe they'll find a love interest a
vixen which forces them to end their
partnership
nah nothing can break this bromance i
wonder if they'll meet midas will they
shoot
or follow him hmm myth chaser episode me
thinks so let's go over to the store
which was built a month ago just outside
holly hedges
we predicted it would become the new
halloween store and lo and behold
you were all right the store is now open
and fully decked out
the detail here is insane from the
battle bus floating above
to the inflatables and the statues like
the skins crying out for people to troll
them
in the center display you know it's
going to happen the added halloween
stuff is great this year
zombies frankenstein's monsters and
loads more are here and
everywhere on the map i'll not break
them all down because there is so many
on this map
[Music]
and now the genome update over the last
two months we've watched as a slurp
juice salesman was blown up by an evil
genius
no it's not your mum it's this guy you
named him
the nominator nice name he's out to rid
the island of gnomes and he's already
tried to blow up barrels of slurp juice
but we foiled that attack he then went
into hiding and left graffiti for us to
find
to let us know he's still plotting from
the shadows right now he's back
and is attempting to poison the vats at
slurpee swamps
we need to cleanse these and of course
the only way to cleanse something
is to jump right in okay that's weird
but
but fortnite has its own rules after
this the nominator straps on a rocket
pack
and escapes i am so confused right now
what is his plan what the hell did i
just witness
where did he get the rocket pack from
please hit me in the comments with your
ideas
let's detective the crap out of this
what's his plan next
so that's our update this time around
halloween has officially dropped in
fortnite
please let me know what i've missed and
i'll shout you out in the next episode
and speaking of shout outs here's more
legends who've used code adamaru
thank you so much for rocking my code i
wouldn't be able to do this without you
if you'd like a shout out please dm me
on twitter my name's adam grenade over
there
with proof of a new item you've bought
and i'll reply and name you in a video
it's the least i can do to thank you i'm
adam from playstation grenade it's been
a pleasure
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you